the new occupiers of the british embassy
in kabul can't understand why the
diplomats have left and not
returned the taliban guards are happy to
be here and insist they're just
maintaining security
the taliban fighters who escorted us say
they've not touched anything
but scattered personal possessions seem
to suggest otherwise
amongst them a british regimental flag a
symbol of the thousands of soldiers who
once fought here
a flak jacket's been slung over a gate
which used to safeguard staff and a food
store room seems to have been ransacked
but the taliban still issued this
astonishing invitation to the british
whenever they want
we welcome them and we want to have
normal relations with them and our
senior officials also want this to
repair and build good relations with
them again
and for the embassies to reopen
but in the nearby canadian embassy
grounds where they found bags and bags
of empty bottles of alcohol the taliban
seemed less inviting
they must have had a lot of money to
drink this much
they used to eat good food get drunk
and then have sex with each other
a curious tortoise was still wandering
around the canadian embassy grounds and
the taliban aren't quite sure what to do
with him
here too there were signs of ransacking
or looting amidst complaints they've
been unfairly judged
where is your help and support instead
you're always shouting with terrorists
come and see the taliban government and
compare us to the previous one
analyze their security and then look at
ours
come and start your work again no one
will hurt you it's diplomatic relations
and it's the right of every country you
must do it and we must do it
the front of the american embassy is
freshly painted with taliban slogans now
and one of the first edicts issued by
the new acting government was designed
to exert more control banning protests
of descent unless permissions being
granted
two afghan journalists who filmed
demonstrations by women demanding rights
showed us their badly bruised bodies
after they were arrested and beaten for
covering what was deemed illegal
they were held separately for four hours
and say around 10 men attacked them with
cables but insist this won't stop them
reporting
has this put you off
reporting has this frightened you too
much
because it's my profession and i will
continue i won't stop i'm informing
people what's happening and no one will
stop us from doing this
it is possible i'll be killed next time
because the taliban don't have mercy on
journalists
on children women on anyone they just do
what they want they only know how to
kill and hit
but it's taliban flags on the streets
and taliban fighters enforcing the rules
and no one is stopping them
and while there's so much uncertainty
there's still a scramble to get out of
the country several hundred boarded the
first international plane to take
passengers out of afghanistan since the
american and other foreign forces left
at the end of august not everyone is
convinced by the taliban reassurances of
safety
alex crawford sky news kabul